well i can tell you that not only has
the prime minister
uh been fined but i can confirm uh that
the chancellor has uh uh received
notification that the metropolitan
police intend to issue them with fixed
penalty notices so um the prime minister
boris johnson and rishi sunak the
chancellor who of course has endured a
torrid a few weeks over his tax affairs
we have just had confirmed uh the uh i
can tell you that a downing street
spokes person has now told sky news uh
this uh the
prime minister and chancellor have today
received notification
that the metropolitan police intend to
issue them with fixed penalty notices
so that is on the record confirmed by a
downing street spokesman and just to
repeat that the prime minister
and the chancellor have received
notification that the mets intend to
issue them with fixed penalty notices uh
no no further details at this stage but
we have been promised an update so this
is grim news for the prime minister and
all his allies who have used
various own words to describe party gate
uh the most colorful perhaps being that
of jacob reese mogg speaking at the
conservative spring conference a couple
of weeks ago
fluff was what uh jacob rees-mogg said
about partygate uh the pm's allies have
tried to dismiss it all as trivial
at a time when
war is waging in ukraine but the fact is
there will be many people i can think
particularly of those campaigners the
bereaved families a couple of weeks ago
when the prime minister
was hosting a dinner from for
conservative mps at a hotel just across
the river from where i'm sitting in
westminster uh there were uh
demonstrators from the covid bereave
families group shouting shame on you and
other
other comments to uh conservative mps as
they arrived there will be real anger
amongst all those people who've lost
loved ones in the covid outbreak and
pandemic
but uh this is
a crisis for the prime minister he may
try and try and shut it shrug it off and
say it doesn't necessarily mean he's
broken the law well
others will not see it that way and as i
say uh dominic rob and the policing
minister uh kip multaz have both said in
recent weeks if you get a fixed penalty
notice you have indeed broken the law so
uh quite dramatic news uh from
confirmation from downing street
following that met statement the prime
minister and the chancellor are to
receive fixed penalty notices as a
result of covered
breaches and coveted regulations uh
relating to a number of parties held in
downing street
during lockdown periods so we await
further details but uh
a lot of people will be shocked many
people will be shocked many people be
angered no doubt the
opposition parties will step up their
demands for the prime minister to go his
allies will say of course another one
cabinet minister uh simon heart the
wealth secretary said it a couple of
days ago on here on sky news it'd be
self-indulgent for the tories to change
their leader here so well we are into a
period of real political turmoil now